you know I guess first let me just ask
you like I don't think we've talked
about how much time did you spend in to
making that engagement perfect and did
it all go the way you wanted it to go
the proposal nothing ever goes there you
want to go like a couple of things
happened that like that that got screwed
up but you gotta kinda like roll with
the punches okay the like there's a lot
of stuff that happened one was I kept
the ring in my drone case and so if you
watched that video of us getting engaged
that's my drone like shooting it I know
and well I got the drones purely for
this and my brothers like are you
getting a photographer and I was like
look at the drone he's like dude no this
is bad plague get a photographer and I
was like what I do the joining so you
can still use the drone it's fine so I
had the drone case I had the ring in the
drone case and and when you go to we
were in the islands and when you go to a
different country and they see a drone
they have to inspect it and so I was
going through like if customs or
whatever and they were like looking
through and I'm like oh my god they're
gonna see they're gonna open it up and
say the next man she's gonna see they
like that the Lorraine Schwartz like
logo thing and then it's gonna be open
then I'm gonna be like well I'm doing
this in the airport there wasn't customs
and been kind of rom-com cool hey what
have we got funny but like I don't know
and then sorry I think I like leveled
with the guy and I was like hey man can
we do this in a different room which I'm
sure is the most terrifying thing to
hear at an airport like oh you ought to
search us let's go into another room but
he was like yeah okay and then we went
over there and then he like opened it up
and I was like it's engaging in there so
play cool and he was like oh yeah yeah
okay fine
and then let me throw Wow so that was
like something that happened that was
interesting also great that that guy
didn't like go to the press with that
yeah I know yeah they had no idea we
were you know it's feasible yeah I don't
know if I could be Islands they know
look if they walk Paris maybe they do
but yeah there were a few hiccups there
yeah but it went it went great and the
wonderful thing about getting engaged is
that generally the woman blacks out and
doesn't remember
anything that happens it's shocking
which is what happened to Sara so I have
now just started to implant things that
didn't house I do remember when the
doves flew up from ba from behind us
remember that sonnet do you remember
when Jack Johnson came out and played
bubble toes behind me right he had to go
because he had a big Joe in Santa
Barbara so she has no recollection of
what really happened which is really
really wonderful because I have we can
map now it's revisionist history that's
amazing yes so overall though I mean an
amazing moment it seems like you you had
put obviously you've gotten her the the
kind of ring she wanted I know she loves
Lorraine Schwartz so you know how much
time did you put into planning this
whole thing well I mean you know it's
it's a million moments over years we had
gone to like when I was looking
nationally we had gone to the ball for
whatever reason like early we were
dating and we're like I don't know if
people do this but I feel like you do
like you go try and rings and like
because you're not like a little
honeymoon stage of dating and so we went
to like a Tiffany's and I was just I was
like what do you what do you like and so
I just made mental notes so like the
things she liked and didn't like and
then like the size of her finger and
then I sent that to Lorraine the long
game it was a long con
Tyler okay he did it right and you
really put in the diamond so yeah well I
mean we're really happy for you and
obviously you guys like where I'm at
with so much love and then you just seem
so happy do you wanna move forward with
wedding planning really quickly chill on
it and talking about things where you
guys that yeah I think we're gonna I
said it before like everyone is so
invested in the next thing yeah you know
like when we started dating it was like
when you guys move again and then once
you moved in was like when you guys
getting engaged and then once we got
engaged yeah it's like it's like hold on
like don't forget that like the
destination isn't what it's about the
journey is what's fun and it's like
we're like a month in to being engaged
and I've never been engaged before and I
assume
I'm never going to be again so I kind of
wanted to just enjoy this little time
and also like Sarah is going to be like
Pinterest boards and vision boards and
like a lot of Elmer's glue is gonna be
involved I'm sure and so I think we're
just holding off on that for just a
little bit just to enjoy like just being
engaged and then yes there'll there will
be a wedding at some point and you will
be invited don't worry so glad to hear
the wedding's coming because you put so
much time into being if you had to pick
a moment from the the proposal or the
time you guys had together after like
cuz it is it's a blur when that happens
is there one moment really god I'll
always remember that like I think she
said or a thing you were able to say or
just a way that you guys got to
celebrate together after the proposal um
that's a good question I mean this is
silly but we kept it a secret for like
two weeks which is very hard to do by
the way and so when we were travelling
back she was like she's obsessed with
the ring which makes me happy like I did
a good job and I was like you guys take
it off while we fly it back because
there's gonna might be paparazzi when we
land and there was also the time there
was a speculation that we had gotten
engaged it was yeah which was funny
because it was like her like Claire's
boutique like faux rings that she had on
I'm at the thing that picture that
everyone thought of us could being
engaged happened
long before we actually got engaged and
so I was like now everyone's expecting
it like so we were flying background so
you got to take that ring off like if
people see that then you know cats out
of the bag and she's like I'm not taking
this off and I was like well you need to
do some things like well let's put on my
other hand and I'll flip it upside-down
and I was like okay that's fine and for
whatever reason we were like going
through customs and then there was like
this huge group of kids who like of
young like high school girls like love
my fiance totally understandable too and
they like know who I am so like there
was like this huge group of kids and
they were like wow but we were in like
the line so we couldn't like go out and
like take pictures with them so we were
just like waving to them and so all
these kids like you know
snapchatting us or whatever kids do the
tick tocking us and so we're like yeah
and so sarah's waving but you have to
understand i told her to turn the ring
around so this gigantic rock is just
like look at it and so she was doing
that I grabbed her head like stop and
then of course I'm sure the kids were
like well such a jerk response
girlfriend to wave at us and that was
just a funny like moment of trying to
hide something that like we surprised
she did knighting in the first place
that's kind of speaks what you're saying
about enjoying it all yeah like you'll
remember all these little stories and by
the way it really seems like the gods
were against you and a couple of things
yeah really push through yeah first a
beautiful here